the agenda's control it's always control  it's power and that's it why would they  teach you to be an entrepreneur they  don't want you to be an Elon Musk they  hate Elon Musk they're obsessed with  this ESG narrative and yeah he's  literally doing Tesla cars how does that  make sense he paid the most taxes and  that's still not enough why because he  is an example that you can achieve and  you can do more and you can be better  why would they teach you to take more  risks but I do think with everything  that's going on in the world right now  we've sort of realized that actually  this idea that we had in the 20th  century whereby have a nice safety net  everything's gonna be okay actually  isn't the best plan which is why I love  Bitcoin because I'm like well that's my  safety net if I don't want to put an  injection inside my body I want to  protest like the truck is in Canada I  don't have to worry about my money being  confiscated because I hold Bitcoin show